dure journée sur des morts et a les
compétences requises
alors on aimerait que tu rejoignes l'air
à hippies dit la brigade fantôme si tu
préfères sa mission cette capture les
crevures les mauvais esprits qui ont
échappé au jugement
son nouveau coéquipier
pour l'avoir mérité en scène nous on est
les meilleurs justifié vivant ou mort la
vue ni la même tête
il a même voix avant et je casse d'être
sérieux un vieux chinois et war
ça va je peux pas lutter c'est mauvais
esprits qui se planquent parmi les
vivants
bon sang je suis comment pour te coller
une balle entre les yeux et point
d'annuler nowicki bonsoir ministère de
la santé où soupçonne d'être mort en
réalité vas-y tu peux lamballe et
delhaize non moi je m'approche pas de ça
ses parents
mara qu'on a la peau dure j'ai encore
super mal si les morts prennent le
pouvoir sur les mini des plans
non
on s'en sort bien
sauf si c'est la fin du monde c'est marc
de chris thomas